es gibt neues von robbie williams ein
überraschungsauftritt allerdings die
musikalische art hätte ich mir gewünscht
aber stattdessen gab es eine sucht
beichte mit den worten ich bin ein
süchtiger mit diesem klaren aber auch
sehr krassen wurden überrascht und
megastar robbie williams an sagt immer
die 500 gäste auf einer gala in saint
tropez so ehrlich wie selten zuvor
sprach robbie über seine alkoholsucht
und andere psychische probleme wir
können
nur um einmal einzuordnen warum ich
eigentlich hier bin ich habe adhs
ich habe depressionen und ich sehe immer
mein spiegelbild verzerrt ich habe
angstzustände bin krankhaft tollpatschig
ich habe sozial angst also vor vielen
menschen wie zum beispiel jetzt gerade
wenn ich rausgehe dann geht es mir
einfach schlecht ich bin immer nervös
und ich habe obsessive zwangsstörungen
also krankhafte angst vor bakterien und
keimen zum beispiel und ich bin
alkoholiker
aber ich bin süchtig aber wenigstens
habe ich einen penis der
unterdurchschnittlich kleine
also das ist ein handy video vom
bildschirm abgefilmt wir haben das
mitbekommen und vor ort instanz hob er
ist unser reporter john kucera ka john
warum gerade jetzt diese beichte und was
war das für eine veranstaltung dort
ja erstmal ein gala abend mit dem titel
evening of discovery des aurora institut
einer organisation die unter anderem von
dem deutschen stein was da christian
angermayer mitgegründet wurde und diese
hat sich zum ziel gesetzt menschen auf
der ganzen welt mit psychischen
problemen zu helfen und einer dieser
unterstützer mamba robbie williams er
war vorher nicht angekündigt und so
größer war die überraschung als der
entertainer mal mit anderen worten auf
die bühne stehen tondo hast selber da an
dem abend wird robbie auf dich gewirkt
und wie kam seine rede war publikum an
die war ja doch sehr offen und sehr
überraschenden aber auch sehr ehrlich
der janina ich glaube ich war genauso
überrascht wie
alle anderen 500 gäste die vor ort waren
man sieht robbie williams man verbietet
man verbindet ihn mit der guten laune
und dann steht da ein entertainer der
plötzlich unsicher dort steht bonn von
karteikarten abliest und auf einmal
seine gesamte krankenakte offen
schonungslos und ehrlich den zuschauern
vorliest und ich muss sagen um mich
herum dachten erst die manche gäste das
wäre ein scherz er würde wieder anfangen
scherz zu machen aber er hat dann im
bogen hinbekommen und nämlich klar zu
machen es ist ernst weil er hat diese
krankenakte vorgelesen um klar zu machen
dass er menschen auf der ganzen welt mit
psychischen problemen helfen will so
selber wie er darunter gelitten hat und
hat dafür eine konzertreihe ins leben
gerufen er demnächst mit verschiedenen
musikerfreunden um auf der ganzen welt
ausrichten wir sind vier konzerte und
jena gesprochen hat zusammen mit dem
aurora institute und da wir damit
auftreten und eben ein zeichen zu setzen
um diesen menschen zu helfen john kucera
ka
vielen dank
[Musik]